تكشف كتائب عز الدين القسام بشكل مستمر عن
اسلحه لمواجهه جيش الاحتلال وفي كل مرحله
من مراحل الحرب تكشف عن نوعيه معينه من
هذه الاسلحه كتائب القسام اعلنت امس عن
تنفيذها عمليتي استهداف لمروحيات جيش
الاحتلال في منطقتي الصفطاوي شمال مدينه
غزه وشرق معسكر جباليا بصاروخ سام 18
للمره الاولى منذ اندلاع الحرب على غزه
لكن ما هو هذا الصاروخ صاروخ سام 18 وما
اهميته في المعركه اذا هو صاروخ روسي مضاد
للطائرات يعرف باسم ايجلا يعود الى مطلع
ثمانينيات القرن الماضي يتم اطلاقه على
الكتف يبلغ مداه حوالي 5000 متر يصل او
تصل سرعته الى 600 متر في الثانيه ويزن
الصاروخ نحو 10 كيلوغرامات يحمل راس
متفجرا بوزن
1.17 كيلوغراما من المواد الشديده
الانفجار ويوجه بالاشعه تحت الحمراء ولا
تستطيع اجهزه الرادار ابطال
عمله ظهرت لدى القسام نسخ سابقه من هذا
الصاروخ منها سام سب سام تس سام 18 الذي
يعد الاكثر تطورا من اجياله السابقه العام
الماضي استهدفت القسام مروحيات اسرائيليه
بصواريخ سام سبعه اثناء تنفيذها لغارات
جويه في قطاع غزه وفق وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه اذا كيف علقتم انتم على ادخال
القسام لصاروخ سام 18 الى المعركه دعونا
نبدا هنا بحساب جمال اذا يقول جمال الكيان
الاسرائيلي دخل بمرحله ما بعد الاستنزاف
باستعماله الطائرات المرو وحيه المزوده
باسلحه النوعيه بكثافه بالاوهو المقاومه
في غزه تدخل السلاح النوعي وصواريخ سام 18
نصل ايضا الى تعليق مصعب يقول حماس اظهرت
استخدامها صاروخ سام 18 امس ولاول مره
وكانها رساله مقصوده في حال تم استخدام
الاباتشي نصل الى
كم اسرائيل ستراجع حساباتها بعد استخدام
حماس 18 يوم
الاباتشي ستكون هي الهدف في المرحله
الثالثه من الحرب واخيرا ننهي التعليقات
بحساب محسن محسن يقول واضح انه لدى حماس
اسلحه تكتيكيه هجوميه ودفاعيه لم تستخدمها
حتى الان واضح انها عامله حسابها لمعركه
طويله تمتد لشهور اخرى اذا صاروخ سام 18
ليست المنظومه الوحيده المضاده للطائرات
التي اعلنت القسام استخدامها في هذه
المعركه فبعد ايام من بدء العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه كشفت كتائب القسام
لاول مره استخدامها منظومه دفاع جوي محليه
الصنع واطلقت عليها اسم متبر واحد
استخدمتها في التصدي لطائرات الاحتلال
خلال عمليه طوفان الاقصى وهذه هي الصور
التي نشرتها القسام وتظهر مقاتليها وهم
يطلقون هذه
الصواريخ يشير خبراء عسكريون الى تحول
الاحتلال الى نمط جديد من القتال واستعمال
طيران الاباتشي لاسناد قواته على الارض
صحيفه يدعوت احرونوت الاسرائيليه كشفت قبل
ايام عن رفض الولايات المتحده طلبا
اسرائيليا بالحصول على مقاتلات اضافيه من
طائرات الاباتشي لتعزيز عملياتها الجويه
قالت الصحيفه ان اسرائيل نشرت مقاتليها من
الاباتشي في غزه لتنفيذ عمليات ضد حزب
الله وفي الضفه الغربيه